if I show up to new planet we go to Mars
or some other planet from a different
solar system and how do we use assembly
index there to discover alien life um in
very simply actually if we let's say
we'll go to Mars with a mass
spectrometer with a sufficiently high
resolution so what you have to be able
to do so good thing about Mass Spec um
is that you can um select a molecule
from the mass and then if it's high
enough resolution you can be more and
more sure that you're just seeing um
identical copies you can count them and
then you fragment them and you count the
number of fragments and look at the
molecular weight and the higher the
number of the fragments the high the
assembly index so if you go to Mars and
you take a mass spec or high enough
resolution and you can find molecules
I'll give guide on Earth if you could
find molecules say greater than 350
molecular weight with more than 15
fragments you have found artifacts that
can only be produced at least on Earth
by
life now you would say oh well maybe the
geological process I would argue very
vly that that is not the case but we can
say look if you don't like the cut off
on
Earth go up higher 30 100 right because
there's going to be a point where you
can find a molecule with so many
different parts the chances of you
getting a molecule that has 100
different Parts um and finding a million
identical copies you know that's that's
just impossible that could never happen
in an infinite set of universes can you
just Linger on this copy number
thing uh a million different
copies what do you mean by copies and
why is the number of copies important
yeah like that was so interesting and
that um
I always understood the copy numberers
was really important but I never
explained it properly for ages um and it
be I kept having this it goes back to
this if I give you a um I don't know a
really complicated molecule and I say
it's complicated you could say hey
that's really complicated but is it just
really random and so so I realized that
ultimate Randomness and ultimate
complexity are
indistinguishable
until you can um you can see a structure
in the randomness so you can see copy
so copies
implies structure
yeah the fact I mean there's a deep
profound thing in there because like if
you just have a
random random process you're going to
get a lot of complex beautiful
sophisticated things mhm what makes
them complex in the way we think life is
complex or um yeah something like a a
factory that's operating under a
selection processes there should be
copies is there like some looseness
about copies
like what does it mean for two objects
to be equal it it's it's all to do with
the the telescope or the microscope
you're using and so at the the maximum
resolution so in the nice thing about
the nice thing about chemists is they
have this concept of the molecule and
they are all familiar with the molecule
and molecules you can hold you know on
your hand lots of them identical copies
a molecu is actually a super important
thing in chemistry to say look you can
have a mole of a molecues and avagadro's
number of molecules and they're
identical what does that mean that means
that the molecular composition the
bonding and so on the configuration is
all is is indistinguishable you can hold
them together you can overlay them so
the way of do it is if I say here's a
bag um of 10 identical molecules let's
prove they're identical you pick one out
of the the out of the bag and you
basically observe it using some
technique and then you put it you take
it away and then you take another one
out if You observe it using technique
you see no differences they're identical
it's really interesting to get right
because if you take say two molecules
molecules can be in different
vibrational rotational States they're
moving all the time so with this respect
identical molecules have identical
bonding in this case we don't even um
talk about chirality because we don't
have a chirality detector so two
identical molecules in one conception
assembly Theory basically um considers
both hands as being the same
um but of but of course they're not
they're different as soon as you have a
chyro distinguisher detect detect the
left and the right hand they become
different and so it's to do with the
detection system that you have and the
resolution so I wonder if there's an art
and science to the which detection
system is used when you show up to a new
planet yeah yeah yeah so like you're
talking about chemistry a lot today we
have kind of standardized detection
systems right of how to compare
molecules so you know when you start to
talk about emojis and language and uh
mathematical theorems
and uh I don't know more sophisticated
things a different scale at a smaller
scale of than molecules at are larger
scale of the
molecules like what
detection like if if we look at the
difference between you and me Lex andly
are we the same are we different sure I
mean of course different close up but if
you zoom out a little bit will
morphologically look the
same you know height characteristics
hair length stuff like that well also
like the species and yeah yeah yeah and
and also there's a sense why we're both
from Earth yeah I I agree I mean this is
the power of assembly theory in that
regard that you if if you so if
everything so the way to look at it if
you have a box of objects if they're all
if they're all in distinguish able um
then using your Technique you then you
what you then do is you then look at the
assembly index now if the assembly index
of them is really low right and they all
they're all indistinguishable then You'
then it's telling you that you have to
go to another resolution so that would
be you know it's kind of a signing scale
it's kind of nice so got it so those two
kind of are attentional with each other
yeah the the number of copies in the
assembly index
yeah that's really really interesting so
okay so you show up to your planet
you'll be doing what I would do M spec I
would bring on a sample of what like
First of all like how big of a scoop do
you take do you just take a scoop like
what like uh so we're looking for
primitive life I would I would look yeah
so if you're just going to Mars or Titan
or Enceladus or somewhere so number of
ways of doing it so you could take a
large scoop or you go for the atmosphere
and detect stuff so and you can make a
um a life meter right so um one of uh uh
Sarah's colleagues ASU Paul Davis keeps
calling it a life meter a life meter
which is quite a nice idea because you
think about it if you've got um a living
system that's producing these uh highly
complex molecules and they drift away
and they're in a highly um kind of
um demanding environment they could be
burnt right so they could just be
falling apart so you want to sniff a
little bit of complexity say warmer
warmer warmer oh we found life we found
the alien we found we found the alien
Elon Musk smoking a joint in the bottom
of the cave on mars or Elon himself
whatever right and say okay found it so
what you can do is the mass spectrometer
um you could just look for things in the
gas phase or you go on the surface drill
down because you want to find molecules
that are you you've either got to find
the source living system because the
problem with just looking for complexity
is it gets burnt away so in a harsh
environment on on on say on the mar
surface of Mars there's a very low
probability that you're going to find
really complex molecules because of all
the radiation and so on if you drill
down a little bit you could drill down a
bit into into a soil that's billions of
years old then I would put in some
solvent water alcohol or something or
take a a scoop put it in put it VI make
it volatile put it into the mass
spectrometer and just try and detect
High complexity High abund molecules and
if you get them hey Presto you can have
evidence of Life MH wouldn't that then
be great if you could say Okay we' found
evidence of life now we want to keep
keep the life meter keep searching for
more and more complexity until you
actually find living cells you can get
those new living cells and then and then
you could bring them back to Earth or
you could try and sequence them you
could see that they have different DNA
and proteins go along the gradient of
the life meter how would you build a
life meter let's say we're together
starting new company launching a life
music Mass spectrometer would be the
first way of doing it just take no no no
but that's that's um that's one of the
major components of it but I'm talking
about like what if it's a device we got
to and branding logo we got to talk that
that's later but what's the input what's
the like how do you get to the um a
metered output so I would I would take a
life so my my life meter our life meter
there you go thank you yeah you're
welcome um uh would have both infrared
and mpect so it would have two ports so
it could Shine the Light um and so what
it would do is you would have a a vacuum
chamber and You' have an electrostatic
analyzer and you'd have a monochromator
to producing infrared um you'd add the
samp so You' take a scoop of the sample
put it in the Life meter it would then
add a solvent or heat up the sample so
some volatiles come off the volatiles
would then be put into the into the mass
spectrom into electrostatic trap and
you'd weigh the molecules and fragment
them alternatively you'd shine infrared
light on them you count the number of
bands but you'd have to in that case do
some separation because you want to
separate in and so in MPC it's really
nice and convenient because you can
separate electrostatically but um you
need to have that can you do it in real
time yeah pretty much pretty much yeah
so let's go all the way back so okay
we're really get this the the Lex's life
me Lex and Lee's life Lex and Lee it's a
good it's a good good uh good to it all
right so um you have a you have a vacuum
chamber you have a little nose the nose
would have um uh
some a a packing material so you would
take your your sample add it onto the
nose add a solvent or a gas it would
then be sucked up the nose and that
would be separated using Chrome what we
call chromatography and then as each
band comes off the nose we would then do
masspec and infrared and in the in the
case of infrared count the number of
bands in the case of massp count the
number of fragments and weigh it and
then the further up in molecular weight
range for the mass spec and the number
of bands you go up and up and up from
the you know dead interesting
interesting over the threshold oh my
gosh Earth life and then right up to bat
crazy this is definitely um you
know alien intelligence that's made this
life right you could almost go all the
way there same in the infrared and it's
pretty simple the thing that is really
problematical is that for many years
decades
what people have done and I can't blame
them is they've rather they've been
obsessing about small biomarkers on that
we find on Earth amino acids like single
amino acids or evidence of small
molecules and these things and looking
for those run looking for complexity the
the be beautiful thing about this is you
can look for um complexity without Earth
chemistry bias or Earth biology bias so
assembly theory is just a way of saying
hey complexity and abundance is evidence
selection that's how our universal life
meter will
work